JOEL WEINBERGER:
Anyway, so yeah,
I'm Joel Weinberger,
as Parisa said.
And I work on a
Chrome security team.
I'm a software engineer.
I focus on a bunch
of different issues,
but tend to focus on user
experience, security, and tools
for developers to help
web developers write
more secure web applications.
And I'm going to talk today
about three things you can do.
So some of the things
we've talked today
may have made you a little
sad, perhaps even a little
depressed about the
state of the world,
but it turns out there's
a lot of things we can do.
And I'm going to talk about
three that I sort of view
as sort of the most important
that we can do as a community
in making our web
applications more secure.
So I want to start at a sort of
basic question though, right?
We have these web browsers that
are running web applications.
And a common
question I get is why
can't the browser just
solve all these problems?
So what does it that
the browser can do?
I work on browser security.
We work on a lot of issues.
There's a couple concrete
things we can do.
We can work on web standards.
And we can make
web standards that
are going to be secure and
provide secure APIs for all web
developers out there.
And this is vitally important,
and we it constantly.
We're Working with all the
other browser vendors out there.
And you can build lots of
secure HTML5 APIs and tools.
That's really vitally important.
Another thing we do, that's
also really important,
is that we actually harden
the web browser itself, right?
And one example this is the
Chrome sandbox, for example.
We harden the browser, so even
if the worst possible things
imaginable happen and
potentially actual code
execution on the machine, we
have this sandbox in place
to make sure that arbitrary
code execution can't happen.
And we try to protect
the users from that.
We also build lots of tools,
both for users and developers,
to help users have a more
secure experience on the web
and try to allow them to
understand what's going on.
We're constantly testing out
new features and web browsers
to make sure users
know what's going on.
This of course raises an
incredibly obvious question,
what can't we do?
Right?
And the answer is
relatively simple actually,
and yet incredibly complex.
We can't stop bugs
and vulnerabilities
in web applications
themselves, right?
There's nothing we
can do in the end
if you have a bug
in your application,
because a bug in
your application
is indistinguishable from
a well formed application
from the browsers perspective.
So I want to talk today
about some of the ways
that, as web developers,
you can take advantage
of some of the tools
that we give you,
as well as take advantage of
things we can't help you with.
And that will make
everybody's lives
easier, but most
importantly for your users.
So we're going to talk
about three things.
We're going to talk
about first class
sanitization in
your application.
And this is actually
really playing off
of what Eduardo was
just talking about,
and I think is really important.
We're then going to talk
about secure communication
in your application.
And it's something that
you may have heard of,
you probably have heard
about, and I hope you have.
But we're going to emphasize
why it's incredibly important.
And then we're going
to talk about security
policies for your
web application.
And the key here is
that each of them
talks about a slightly different
aspect of a web application.
So we're going to first
talk about sanitization,
which is about what happens
before your application leaves
your server.
We're going to talk about
communication, which
is what happens as it goes
across over to the browser.
And then finally,
we'll talk about what
happens once it's
actually there.
So let's get started and
talk about sanitization
as a first class feature.
Obviously we've been talking a
lot about cross site scripting
tonight, and for good
reason, but let's just
do a quick recap here.
Really simple example.
Imagine you're developing
a web forum, right?
Really simple application.
You expect comments
on your web forum.
And you know it's
going to be just sort
of simple textual
comments, which
are going to come from
users who are untrusted.
Naturally, you're
nightmare scenario is this.
A comment ends up on your page,
which is just a script tag
and is going to
execute arbitrarily
bad things on your web page.
So the fundamental problem
here, as a sort of alluded to,
is that the web browser
has no idea what's bad
and what's good.
From the web
browser's perspective,
this is all just content coming
from the web application.
So the real secret here
is that you actually
have to figure this out before
reaches the web browser,
because the web browser won't
know the good from the bad.
So this is a really
common pattern
that I've seen in
many web applications.
I've even written it for
myself at some point.
You're writing your
web application,
and as hopefully you got
a sense of from Eduardo,
perhaps this is not
the right approach,
but you're going to
have some content.
It's going to have
some user data in it.
And so let's make sure there's
no angle brackets in there,
right?
Because then we can be
sure that those script
tags aren't going to appear.
And indeed, if your user
data is a script tag,
it's going to take all
those angle brackets
and replace them,
and you'll get that
as your output, which,
if you'll notice,
is just some harmless text.
That's a little messy looking.
You probably don't want that
appearing in your web forum,
but compared to
some of the trolling
that happens in web forums
that's nothing, right?
So we're happy.
That's a good day.
Another example, perhaps
you're taking URLs,
and you're going to put
them on your web page.
So we get some user data, and
it's an untrusted user data.
You filter out the
angle brackets,
and you ex output
it to your page.
And you're good to-- rats!
We missed it, right?
In this case, there
was no angle bracket,
because we're talking
about some content that's
going to appear as URL.
And that's a different
context from the original one
we were talking about, which
was sort of in the PC data area,
as it's called, which is
sort of the general area
that HTML tags appear.
And it turns out that, as we've
been discussing all night long,
this is just so
incredibly complex.
And if you're going to start
writing your own sanitization,
as we were doing here by
replacing angle brackets,
you're really going to have
to know a lot of details.
And there's been a bunch of
academic research on this,
and this is sort of
an academic model that
was developed that explains
a lot of the details.
And I don't to get
too technical on you,
but if you want to roll
your own sanitizations
you really are going
to have to understand
that the relationship between
all these transducers and sub
grammars.
And you got to really understand
all these relationships,
and-- no, no.
You're doing it wrong.
Right?
If you ever have to think
about something like this
in web design, you're
totally doing it wrong.
You shouldn't ever have to
think about the model of the web
browser.
And so the real
answer is that you
have to build this into
your web flow, right?
You have to have this as
part of your development
as you're going along.
And it turns out that most
frameworks that you're
using today probably
have tools that
are already available to you.
And you should be
using those tools,
and taking full
advantage of them,
and using them to the
best your ability.
So just off the top my head,
there are tools in CodeIgniter,
in Django, in C template.
There's the XSS terminate
plug-in for Rails.
And while none of
these cover every case,
they're a really good start.
And if you're doing any sort
of work with these frameworks,
you really need to be doing it.
And as Eduardo was talking
about, if it doesn't exist,
you need to get on top
of that and make sure
that the developers actually
build these tools in,
because they're so important
for how this is going to work.
So just taking a simple
example of to give
an example of how
this could work.
This comes from the GWT
SafeHtml templates library,
which is one of my
favorite libraries.
It just does a really great job.
Full disclosure it's the
Google Web Toolkit library.
And basically, if you just
take a look at this example,
it's building a template,
which, at compile time,
can sort of determine
safely where you're
going to be outputting
untrusted data into.
And in this really
simple example,
you take the user data,
which is eventually
going to go into this
template, and automagically it
knows where this data
is going to here,
and it knows the proper
sanitization to apply.
So when the bad
guy actually takes
one of these crazy URL
based attacks on you,
instead just replacing
the angle brackets,
it's going to replace
the correct thing.
And it's going to know to
take out that JavaScript colon
and make everything safe, right?
And the whole thing
here is that you just
had to sort of describe the
behavior of your web page.
You didn't have to think
about sanitization.
You want it just sort of
be a part of your workflow.
And I think you'll find
that once you sort of make
it a part of your
workflow, it'll
make everything
you're doing easier.
You just won't have to
think about it anymore.
And really, the
whole point here is
that you may make it
as easy as possible.
It's simple.
You're just describing what your
web page is going to look like
and everything gets
taken care for you.
So that's the first thing
you have to do, right?
You have to make sure that stuff
that comes out of your server
and goes to your user
will actually be safe.
So try to take advantage
of the tools that
are available to you.
But let's talk about what
happens when your data actually
leaves your web page.
It goes to the wire.
It's ready to go
to the web browser
and have the user
interact with it.
So I think most of us
have a model of how
HTTP communication works, right?
Sort of basic web traffic.
We have a web browser,
and you have a server,
and data goes back and
forth between the two,
and they communicate.
Except it turns
out that this isn't
in any way how it
actually works, right?
It's actually a
giant messy cloud.
It's going through a
lot of different things.
There's many web servers
between you and the other side.
There are guys with
black hats on who
are trying to steal your data.
It goes through many types of
agencies and things like that.
And there's all sorts of
other bad and horrible things
in between.
And the main thing
is you have no idea
where it's going
between the two, right?
You have no control over it.
And that's sort of, actually,
the beauty of the internet.
And so you're worried
about these attacks.
And you're worried
about people sitting
in between you and your users.
Except that one of
the more common things
I hear when talking to
web developers yeah,
but that's sort of a
ridiculous scenario.
No one's actually sitting
between me and my users.
A couple years ago there
was this great demo
that was given that
was-- calling it
a demo is really
underselling it.
It was a great example
application of an attack.
It was called Firesheep.
And what Firesheep
did was you could--
it was an extension for Firefox.
And you could go anywhere
you had access to Wi-Fi.
Coffee shop, Google
guest, wherever.
And you could sit around.
You could turn on
this extension.
And it would just
silently record
all the data it's seeing,
and it would pull out
all the authentication
tokens and login
cookies for all the social
networking websites that
were flying over in
the ether around you.
And it gave you
this beautiful UI,
where you could just
click on a button
and log in as another user
and act on their behalf.
This could not have
been more trivial.
You just got a menu of
choices of different users
that were in that
room with you, and you
could be whoever you
wanted to be, right?
And this was a really,
very real attack.
And actually it was
happening pretty regularly.
And of course, once
everybody got a handle on it,
no coffee shop was safe.
But the most common
retort I get to this
is, but there's nothing
sensitive on my site, right?
And for many websites
that's true, right?
There's a lot of
websites that are just
news websites, things like that.
Or whatever, maybe you're just
not that worried about it.
And that's fair.
People aren't logging in.
But let's talk about a different
problem you might have.
So say your website-- I use
"The New York Times" regularly,
so I always use
it in my examples.
And you're delivering
your page to your user.
But as we discussed, you're
not actually doing that, right?
You're actually going through
a lot of guys in the middle.
We call this a man
in the middle attack.
And these people, if
you're using HTTP,
can be modifying your page
however they see fit, right?
So in this case, I'm
making up the silly example
of their adding a
script to your page
to add ads your
page, which means
that when this page
actually reaches your user,
they're not going to see the
add that you placed there.
They're going to see some
other ad for some other website
that they want to
control and appear there.
I know it sounds like a
sort of silly example.
Who's adding ads
on the fly, right?
And that's a fair point.
That's a fair point.
So I was on the Southwest
Airlines the other day.
I This could not have
been more perfect.
I was on Southwest Airlines,
and I was working on this talk.
I took a break to read
"The New York Times,"
and I wanted to go to the
menu of "The New York Times,"
and I wanted to get
back to the front page.
For the life of me, I
couldn't find the menu.
I couldn't figure out
what was going on.
And after about two
minutes, I noticed
that wonderful
Southwest banner add
at the top was not a
Southwest banner ad.
It was content that was
injected by Southwest Airlines.
I was on the Southwest
Airlines Wi-Fi,
and they were putting
this content my page.
It had some helpful information
about the flight tracker
or whatever, but I actually
couldn't navigate around
the website.
"The New York Times" was
in no way controlling
the content that was
appearing on my page.
Totally benign.
But I sat there for
two minutes furious
at "The New York
Times," not realizing
that they weren't
at fault for this.
And so really that's
sort of the key here.
Is that this giant
banner at the top,
in no way part of
"The New York Times."
And integrity is really
important to your users.
Hopefully it's important
to you as well,
because you want your users
to get the content that you
expect to appear on their page.
Fortunately, there's an answer.
And it's called HTTPS.
Many of you are probably
familiar with this.
It's what gives you that
wonderful green lock
in many web browsers
on many websites.
And HTTPS is HTTP plus privacy,
integrity, and authentication.
And these are all
fancy terms that
mean that they let the data that
you expect to get to your user
without any of the bad
guys in between seeing it.
And it does is using a bunch of
fancy cryptography primitives
and fanciness that
nobody cares about.
Doesn't matter.
What matters is that provides
a guarantee of the content
getting to your user
in a way you expect.
And it is just absolutely vital
that your websites use this.
There is no website that
shouldn't have HTTPS.
I say that as a very
strong statement.
If you want to
argue that with me,
we could talk about
it afterwards,
but I promise you're wrong.
So at a very fundamental
level, just keep in mind
that without HTTPS, you
don't control anything
on your web page.
This is the very
most basic point.
There's nothing that's
getting to your user that
is what you expect it to be.
So I want to have a couple
really cool features
that are a little more advanced
and only bad asses need apply.
So let's have a basic
problem with HTTPS.
You try to go to your page.
In this case, let's
say is it's google.com,
and we have this man in the
middle, between you and Google.
And the man in the
middle, he's not
going to try to
read your traffic,
because you're over HTTPS.
You're Superman.
You can't have your
traffic be read, right?
That's great.
So he redirects you.
And he says oh sorry.
Sorry, user.
I actually don't support HTTPS.
You should really use
HTTP to access google.com.
And what happens?
Well, you happily
say OK, I'll use HTTP
because I want to
get to my content.
And then you go through
the man in middle,
and then you eventually
to the server.
But now you're going over
HTTP, and the man in middle
can read all your
user's traffic, right?
This is terrible.
And we've lost all the
protections that HTTPS gave us.
There is a solution.
There is a way.
And it's called HSTS, which is
HTTP strict transport security.
And the basic notion is, if
we had an initial connection,
let's assume it
gets to the server.
And after that
initial connection,
it returns some
content, but it also
returns a signal to the
web browser that says,
you know how you connected
to me over HTTPS?
You should always
connect to me over HTTPS,
and you should do that forever.
Or sorry, not forever.
You should do it for an
extended period of time.
The browser takes
that information,
and it stores it
to the side, along
with some other important
information about its keys
and things like that.
Stuff that you don't
need to worry about.
And it stores that information
going forward for a time
that you specify.
And you can do
this so trivially.
You just have to specify an
HTTP header, strict transport
security, where you
specify a max age for what
you want to support
this in seconds.
And the browsers will hold
onto this information.
So that when we go back, and
we have this same attack where
the man in the middle
tries to redirect you,
the browser gets that redirect.
And it checks against his
HSTS list, and it says nope.
Sorry.
I know that something's
going wrong.
There's probably an
attack against me.
And so the browser
stops, and you actually
get a particularly nasty
page in most web browsers
that support this that
doesn't let you click through
or proceed.
And this is really important,
because, in these cases,
it almost always means
there's an attack going on.
Almost always.
And so this is a
really cool thing.
You may have noticed
that I punted
on something slightly,
which is that it requires
an initial connection
to the server.
And if the man in the middle
is there in the beginning,
you're going to have a sad day.
But wait, we have a
solution for that too.
And it's called the
STS preload list.
And it's currently supported
by Chrome and Firefox.
And basically
there's a list that
comes with your web
browser that gives you
a list of a bunch of
websites that opt into this
and say we want to
support STS, and here
are the key that we use.
And we expect to
always be over HTTPS.
And this way it solves
the bootstrapping problem,
because, the first
time you connect,
you already know that
these websites support STS,
and that's how you want
the website to operate.
As a web developer,
it's really quite easy.
You just have to contact Chrome.
There's a proof of identity
kind of thing that goes on.
And then your
website is actually
hard coded onto the
STS list, preload list.
And Chrome and
Firefox will get that.
So this is a really,
really important mechanism
for preventing these attacks.
But even if you just do the
strict transport security
header, that's a great start.
It's a major improvement
over the status quo.
So the real thing is you really
should be setting up HTTPS
today if you haven't.
It's the only way to
guarantee that your users get
the content you expect.
There's also this
bad rumor that's
been going around
for years, years,
that HTTPS is difficult to set
up and that it's expensive.
So if you're a non commercial
website or, I believe actually
including personal
websites, there
are actually several
certificate vendors
that will actually give
you a free certificate.
I'm a really cheap guy, and
I have a personal website,
but I got a free
certificate out of it,
so I can attest to the
fact that this is possible.
If you're a
commercial enterprise,
there's varying levels of cost.
They can be quite cheap.
I forget what the
numbers run these days.
But it's also really easy.
I have some links here
to both the website
that explains in
great detail how
to set up HTTPS for your server,
as well as best practices
to sort of help you avoid
making any common errors.
So later on, hopefully you'll
check that out and do it,
because there's just
really no reason
not to be doing it today.
So lets got to the
last part here.
So far we've talked about making
sure that your content as safe
as it leaves your server.
Then we talked about what
happens while it's actually
between your server
and the browser.
But there's one
obvious part left.
What happens once
it's in the browser?
And that's why we're going to
talk about security policies.
Let's take a look
at this guy here.
Looks like a good
patriotic American.
Looks like he's a wise man.
But he's doing
something that is just
vitally important from
a security perspective.
And I want you to look
carefully here for a second.
Really want to emphasize this.
He has belt and suspenders.
We believe in defense in depth.
And I'm a security
guy, and I practice
what I preach, so I always go
belt and suspenders myself,
right?
It's the only way to
be properly secure.
guarantee security.
But seriously, from a
security perspective,
we believe in defense in depth.
You want to have multiple
layers of security.
And you want to make sure
that that ultimate enemy is
cascading failures, right?
You want to make sure that
if you have any problems,
that once you get
past that first level,
you have something there to
defend yourself afterwards.
So let's talk abut
content security policy,
which is a relatively
new technology.
It's been around
for a couple years,
but it's really
gotten steam of late.
So this is a basic
header that you
can provide to your website.
And it's going to allow you
to do some really cool things
about telling the browser what
content should and should not
be allowed on your website.
So say your foobar.com.
Note https://foobar.com,
of course.
I can provide this header today.
It's an HTTP header.
And it's doing a couple things.
The first is this
script source thing,
which is a white list
of sources that I
expect scripts to come from.
Pretty straightforward.
In particular in this
example, it expects scripts
from self, which is the same
origin, so in this case,
from foobar.com.
And it also allows
scripts from, you
can specify other
arbitrary sources as will.
In this case, API is .googl.com.
And what this is
basically telling
us is taking this sort of
silly a web forum example
from before, if we
have some user input,
we're obviously expecting
something totally benign.
But should something
somehow make it
to our server, which
will never happen,
because we're sanitizing
properly in the server.
But just imagine it
gets through somehow.
It's going to actually check to
see, before it runs the script,
is this script on
the white list,
and because it's
neither from foobar.com
or from apis.google.com, the
browser actually stops it.
So I fibbed a little
bit earlier when
I said there's nothing a
browser can do in identifying
good content from bad content.
There is.
If the web application
tells the browser
what good content looks like
and what bad content looks like.
And content security policy
is how you can do this today.
So basically the
fundamental idea
here is we have all these
bad things happening.
And you'll note that even
in that silly example
we'll stop that content
from appearing, which
would make that website
look a little funky.
But that's OK, because we've
taken this evil attack,
and we just turned
it into a bug.
And ultimately, that's a
happy place to be in, right?
Mistakes happen.
Things can go wrong.
And that's why we're going to
have this defense in depth.
So let's talk about how
this actually is working.
I sort of breezed over it there.
The basic idea is that
we have this white list
of scripts sources.
Like I said, in this case, we
have self, so the same origin,
foobar.com, but also
apis.google.com.
So when I try to load evil.js,
it's is coming from some source
I don't recognize.
We simply don't allow it.
There's a couple other
things it has to do though.
You might have
thought about the fact
that we have these
inline scripts.
And I didn't specify where
those are allowed to come from.
And indeed, they sort of do
come from the same origin,
but that's one of the more
common attack vectors.
So we actually have
to stop inline scripts
from executing as well.
It's a little problematic
because, as you
might have been able to
guess, the doEvil script
from the browser's
perspective is
indistinguishable from the
my legitimate code script.
So we're going to have
to stop that one as well.
We do have ways of
dealing with that.
I'm not going to
get into that today,
but there's some magical things
called script hast and script
nonce, which actually do
allow inline scripts that you
want to white list to execute.
But just know that that's
sort of the minor detail here.
There's one more detail.
Everybody's favorite
friend, eval.
If that input is
something you don't
want, of course
that will execute.
So we're going to have to
do-- from a security guy's
perspective, what I've
always wanted to do.
We're going to ban eval.
No more eval.
That's great.
And these three things
combined, for the most part,
in most traditional
XSS cases, will prevent
XSS There are some corner cases,
but for most traditional XSS,
it's gone.
So even if you
sanitization falls apart.
You'll have this
baseline of security
ready to prevent things
from attacking your users.
But there's a bunch of other
really cool things going on
as well.
What I described
as script source
there sort of works-- we have
similar directives for style,
images, and forms as well.
So you can specify a
white list of the style
that you expect to
be on your page,
for images that you
expect to be on your page.
All types of content.
And this is just to give an
example of why this might
matter, poor "New
York Times" again.
If an ad comes along, and it
was expected to load content
from one source, but
switches it at the end,
"The New York Times"
would be very sad.
And in fact, this has
happened a couple years ago.
They actually had a case where
an ad switched the content
that it was loading
before the ad was actually
put on the pages.
And instead of being a benign--
I forget what it was supposed
to be for-- it ended up
being one of these giant,
full screen fake
anti-virus attacks.
So you really want to make
sure the content you expect
on your pages is actually
what will appear.
I also want to quickly
go CSP reporting, which
I think is one of
the coolest features
and certainly one of
the least talked about.
So here we have this policy
that is very similar to what
we have been talking
about the whole time.
And basically what's
going to happen
is that in addition
to the script source,
we have a report uri.
And if we have a
violation-- so this
is script that's being
loaded by an attacker--
it'll of course be
blocked by our policy,
because we're not allowing stuff
from evil.com to be loaded.
It's going to the report uri.
And it's going to
return to your server
a big JSON blob of all the
information about the failed
attack.
And you know we must be doing
something right, because I said
JSON, and everyone
loves big data
and analyzing lots
of JSON blobs.
But it's going to give you
all this cool information
about what was violated,
how it was violated,
when it was violated,
so on and so forth.
And I know this sounds
kind of trivial,
but there's a couple
important things here.
One, it's always of
course wonderful to know
about what attacks are actually
being attempted in the wild.
But the more important one
is that, even if you're
afraid of turning on CSP,
you're afraid of if you
got that white list
totally correct,
there's no reason you can't
start reporting immediately.
You can go into a report only
mode, where you don't actually
enforce the directives, but you
just have the reporting happen.
And you can use that to learn
about what sorts of attacks
are actually happening.
And Netflix has actually done
this on some of their sites.
I forget exactly which sites,
but some of their sites
that they run.
Netflix has actually turned
on CSP in report mode
to find out what's actually
been going on in the wild.
And they actually
found a whole host
of attacks that were
going on against them.
They filtered out
the benign stuff,
and they actually
found real attacks.
Even just by being
in reporting mode,
they were able to stop real
attacks on their users.
And this is just the
tip of the iceberg.
There's just a huge amount of
more that goes on with CSP.
CSP has been growing a lot.
There's a frame
busting prevention.
Sandbox iframes is using CSP.
We have some really cool stuff
that's in the standards bodies
right now about guaranteeing
the integrity of resources
that you're loading.
And also we're working on
some stuff about sub origins
and having more fine
grained origins.
So I highly encourage you
to check out more about CSP.
And this is sort of the line.
You can turn on CSP today with
this one tiny HTTP header.
Now for many sites it'll have
to be more complicated depending
on what you're loading.
But I highly encourage you
to, at the very least, look
at report only
mode, so you can see
what's going on
in the wild today.
On html5rocks.com, there's
some great tutorials
on content security policy.
It's a great site for
other reasons too.
But again, CSP,
super easy to use.
And once it's on and
once you have a policy,
you shouldn't really have to
think about it very often,
if ever.
It's all about easy.
Perhaps you've seen that
as a theme of this talk,
but security doesn't
have to be hard.
It can be just a part
of your workflow.
So just as a last thought,
I encourage you to go out.
Just look at your tools that
you have in your workflow today.
Think about how you actually
are preventing security today.
And if you're not
doing everything
you possibly can for
your users, at least
go out and try these three.
At least try to get
these three started.
But thank you so much
for being here today,
and I will be around
for questions later.
[APPLAUSE]